i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and jan hey guys
it's me anne and i am back with another
makeup tutorial this time
it's gonna be one of my favorite looks
honestly it is a color
blocked cat eye
so my base is already on and i'm going
to move on to the eyes starting with my
eyebrows i micro bladed my eyebrows so
that is essentially semi permanently
tattooing them on i want to say four
years ago and it is hands down one of
the best decisions i've ever made it
makes getting ready so so so much faster
however i do still like to put a little
bit of product in it i usually use like
a tinted eyebrow gel this one is from
thrive it's kind of a dark eyebrow gel
and i will usually go in and brush my
eyebrows up so what i think of this does
is it kind of lifts the face it kind of
makes your eyebrows a little bit bushier
and also by using a brow gel kind of
makes your eyebrow hair eyebrows look a
bit thicker
because you are kind of accentuating
them and lifting them up so i go in with
a little spoolie and start the front and
brush up
and that's what counts
alright
so moving on to the eye makeup
getting two gel eyeliners here these are
actually the kbd beauty
um brow pomades but you can use them on
your eyes and they're such fun colors
and they're very long wearing i pretty
much only use them for this purpose
getting an angled brush i'm going to
start working on my lids so my base is
already done here it's got a little bit
of concealer on lots of sunscreen some
blush so we're going to focus on the
eyes today so i am getting some red i'm
playing with red and blue here which i
think is a beautiful color combo i think
blue eyeliner with red lipstick is such
a stunning combination we're going to do
blue and red on the eyes so let's do it
so i'm going to line the top of my lid
with some of the red but stop in the
center of my eyelid
and because i'm doing a color block look
and i want to be pretty clean i'm taking
my brush and as i'm getting to the
center i'm just drawing a line
down so that it feels almost like a
rectangular like i squared it off at the
end
[Music]
so those two
red pieces of the eyeliner are down so
i'm taking the blue that i have now and
i'm gonna finish off the liner here what
i'm gonna do is i'm going to finish off
and create a cat eye shape with this
eyeliner and what's gonna do is it's
gonna create this beautiful color
blocked effect between the red and blue
when it comes to any cat eye really i
usually like to make the wing first and
then connect which is exactly what i
just did
you should be careful though once you
get to the center because you want to
maintain that line
then
lots of mascara as per usual
[Music]
a little bit of lip gloss
[Music]
a little bit of highlighter so this is i
already have sunscreen on but i'm going
to put a little bit more sunscreen
because i love this superfood glow
screen it's a kind of pearly highlighter
ish sunscreen that has spf 40 so a
little bit extra sunscreen never hurt
[Music]
honestly such a fun way to play with
multiple colors to play with color
blocking pretty easy if you practice
like it is a little a little bit more
precision than your classic cat eye but
the line down the middle the distinction
between the two colors isn't too hard if
you have a little bit of patience and a
good fine eyeliner brush
and that's it guys this is
honestly a look that i would wear
absolutely anywhere because it's just a
riff on your classic classic cat eye
shape it's still going to give you that
elongating of the eyes that cat eyes do
but you're doing using some kind of fun
colors to do it so i hope you guys
enjoyed it and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you